you guys get the Trap you know what
happened Dwayne I know what you're
trying to do um the whole world Seas I
just got off social media and other
players around the league seeing it so
um it is what it is you know ref Miss
calls sometimes but you know when
they're a bit that obvious you know it's
tough and obviously with you and Kevin
both having five fouls you guys were
taking a but it was desperation that you
do whatever you can what was the
explanation that you heard from the refs
I didn't get one okay
there was some question from the Lakers
saying maybe you had fouled him prior to
that I stopped my hands are back uh
Reeves tried to draw a foul and once we
bumped into each other um you know I
think he was trying to get the ball back
since then and you know that's a good
three four five seconds to build up
before LeBron grabbed the referee and
called the timeout you guys had the big
comeback in the second half right out of
halftime CU it hurt worse to kind of
have te decided by you know Tournament
game and all that yeah um you know when
they put so much into anticipation on
the game you know we're not asking for
favoritism just a fair chance um and
even before the game in the pregame
huddles as a team we'd come in and be
like we understand what type of game
it's going to be just keep playing all
the way through it and we continue to
play uphill battle the whole time and
you know to watch it unfold like that
tough what explanation did you give them
when they made that call um I said he
didn't have the ball you can't call a
timeout then um I don't know if it's
something that the refs can come
together on and decide I mean that still
takes away our layup opportunity but you
know it's still better than giving them
the ball back did they off did they
offer any response when you no you know
it they just look at you look back in
that situation coach was
saying